katy s'est pas vraiment non ce n'est pas
mon vrai nom savant de travail tout à
fait tu viens d'où heures moi je viens
d'un milieu tout à fais et ouais on vit
très bien la maison points et
donc suivi des études jusqu'en terminale
je les terminales bep et un bac
non j'ai là que la première partie
français jacques gillot non je voulais
faire un fuite par un médical et pendant
son adolescence trouver quoi j'allais en
discothèque
je rigolais bien
j'avais donc des amis qui était beaucoup
plus âgée que moi et qui lui je tenais
donc j'ai commencé à me shawn et vers
l'âge de 16 ans comment ça s'est passé
la première fois la première fois
c'était
un petite amie d'une de mes amies qui
avait 35 36 ans à peu près avec l'âge
elle arrive un an il lui filer du pognon
nous filer du pognon à tout appel et ont
valu ma présente et que l'on sait plus
pas mutuellement et puis on va te
présenter à son petit ami
oui femme sa chose à ne jamais faire est
jamais présenté son ami
rapide et massive comme sa saison lui 35
ont mis 35 ans qui va commencer à te
filer du pognon aussi tout à fait un
restaurant cadeau en tout à faire de
l'argent ont de l'argent qui est très
intéressant c'est une et combien ça
dépend où donner 5 6 ans a quand même et
en faisait quoi cet argent
cet argent ben j'ai ajouté qu' folie
avec je m'achetais des choses des
chaussures des
les ensembles surtout tu as quel âge
maintenant j'ai 20 ans et ça fait
combien de temps que michelin 4 4 ans
mais ma maman
si si je vais m'arrêter je vais arrêter
merci j'ai des ambitions quand même et
ça consiste en quoi alors on a mis
challenge oui en fait quand on dit
micheline c'est quelqu'un qui a un
travail c'est régulière oui c'est bien
mais c'est quelqu'un qui a un travail et
qui fait ça pour arrondir ses fins de
mois jusque là et qui a des ambitions
qui veut réussir dans la vie
quel camp elle commence par ça et moi
mes ambitions personnelles sont d'ouvrir
une société d'informatique
tu bosses dans l'informatique bonne là
je bosse en informatique à mi temps je
prends des cours de programmation
c'est très sérieux très sérieux raconte
comment ça se passe
tu fais ça ou d'abord sur paris oui je
ne citerai pas nous je vais pas dire le
quartier non je vais toujours dans des
endroits très chic est vraiment parce
que c'est là où on peut trouver les
personnes vous intéressante on comment
ça se passe pour lui ce n'est quand je
vais aborder une personne je fais
d'abord vu et jules trine je regarde
donc si les personnes qui sont donc très
très bien de ce team enterre tout nouvel
cimentaire est un jeu vous demander du
feu puis généralement ça se passe
ensuite parce que la personne sans
donc ça se passe très bien comment ce
que j'ai toujours d'ailleurs
je suis plutôt très chic ouais on tient
compte du feu et puis et puis bon ben on
vient je vous offre un pot et puis comme
je commence à lui dire oui mais honda du
pot c'est 500 francs pour une fellation
et 1000 francs pour la passe plus
l'hôtel
voilà alors la fellation se passe
toujours dans la voiture donc la
personne met un préservatif parce
qu'avec le sida attention voilà avoir
des problèmes et dans la voiture ce
n'est dans l'hôtel on va dans un hôtel
dans un tel jeu n'en mangent l'habitude
d'aller japonais 3,4 c'est dur quand
même quand la fellation ça peut durer
minutes avant les grèves
et puis la passe c'est une heure si tu
as vite au restaurant c'est après ou
avant
c'est avant tout avant et après c'est
fini après on prend on fait une petite
oie l'air déjà en arrivant les aptitudes
toilette intime et avant de repartir
moment ce n'est toi et puis on se quitte
comme ça je vais m'habituer au régulier
jeunes et des clients réguliers oui
surtout pour la les massages à domicile
mais c'est déjà tombés sur des maniaques
jamais la vapeur si ça fait un peu peur
mais ça c'est les risques du métier
tais toi dans ton sac tu as une bombe
j'ai un grand réseau art une valise
gabon les oiseaux waring bon le mec se
prendre un bon coup de rasoir
je voulais pas te regarde et vois là et
c'était combien à peu près par mois
d'argent
alors quand ça marche très très bien
avec le must linge et des massages je me
suis à peu près vingt mille francs
c'est pas mal pas mal non et dans
l'informatique tu viennes convient à
beaucoup sera touché 150 francs ah oui
c'est vrai que ça laisse rêveur au
malawi était des mecs habituellement une
rallonge des fois pour leur faire des
trucs un peu spéciaux ou si le mec va un
truc un peu particulier oui ça m'est
déjà arrivé à une personne qui était
donc je suis pour lui faire un massage
et il m'a demandé l'été scato ouais
pathologie bon alors là je vais demander
quand même ça ça en plus c'est pas
beaucoup en plus quand même oui c'était
pas beaucoup mais
faut quand même pas trop demander un
abandon qu'il avait déjà payé 500 francs
de massage cette fois encore leur sont
propres
quand même oui enfin quand je peux tirer
je tire mais bon se trouver que cette
personne il mais pas trop un système à
d'autres comme bizarreries
sinon il ya beaucoup d'hommes du très
très connues notamment un qui se fait on
entendu donc parle énormément de vie pas
ces derniers temps les tarifs de prendre
du plaisir avec les mecs quand la
personne ne se donne pas sa s'est
contenté d'un temps qu'à fermiers
plaisir le vaut mieux prendre du plaisir
voilà en train d un impact a eu envie de
revoir simplement parce qu'il plaisait
pour le plaisir
ainsi comme ça mais j'en ai envie mais
je veux faire je ne ferai jamais parce
que ces business business business
business était jamais honte de faire ce
que tu fais non pourquoi je trouve que
c'est pas plutôt de faire ce que je fais
que plutôt un métier un quelconque ses
parents ils savent pas ça
mes parents ne savent pas non et s'ils
le savaient ben ça risquerait de leur
faire beaucoup de peine à des frères des
soeurs âgées décédées seraient les
frères le savent mais ça le savons parce
que deux ben c'est ma vie quoi ça les
regarde pas elles font pas ça non
un juno régulier non j'ai pas de petite
taille 9 envie de la voir non pas pour
les 100 g je suis jeune j'ai 20 ans j'ai
tout le temps de penser à l'avenir
côté foyer je peux pas rentrer dans ce
milieu où ces travail maison de dos
pas du tout nananère ça prend quand même
temps encore cinq ans à peu près et aura
mis combien d'argent de côté
je pourrais pas dire au moins je ne
saurais pas trop ni trop peu près voit
en gros si c'est quand ça marche très
soucieux ta boîte oui ça suffira que je
peux avoir un petit apport personnel
gamin
de la famille tu penses quoi les hommes
les hommes devant les hommes sont tous
les mêmes
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'ina l'institut
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus